hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a really neat problem from a
german math competition
start out with triangle abc
and its inscribed circle
we'll draw a tangent to this inscribed
circle and label its points d and e
the diagram is not to scale
in triangle abc
a b is equal to 3
bc is equal to 5 and c a is equal to 6.
d e is tangent to the in circle or
inscribed circle of the triangle abc
what is the perimeter of triangle c d e
again this comes from a german math
competition known as the kangaroo
dermatomatic
you had to solve 30 problems in 90
minutes with no
calculator can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
before i explain the solution i want to
go over a key geometric principle
segments tangent to a circle from an
exterior point are equal
so consider a circle
and we'll take an exterior point a
we'll draw a tangent to the circle at
point b and we'll draw another tangent
to the circle and label that point c
we want to prove that the length of a b
is equal to the length ac
how do we do that
well
because the line segments are tangent to
the circle
we can draw radii
each with the length of the radius of
the circle r
that form right angles at points b and
c so here's a right angle at point b
and we can do the same thing to point c
and each of these segments have length r
because they are radii of the same
circle
now we'll connect a to the circle center
with length w
because we have right triangles we can
use the pythagorean theorem
we can calculate that a b is equal to
the square root of w squared minus r
squared and ac has the same length
thus a b is equal to ac
so we're going to use this principle
many times to solve this problem
so how can we figure out the perimeter
of triangle c d e
well let's look at the pertinent parts
of the question
and now
let's think about what we need to solve
for
let's suppose this tangent point is
labeled f
this tangent point is labeled g
and the tangent point between d e and
the in circle is
j now suppose e j is equal to x
by the principle of equal tangence
g e is also equal to x
suppose that d j is equal to y
by the principle of equal tangence df is
also equal to y
so if we want to calculate the perimeter
of triangle cde
this will be cd plus ce plus the length
of de
this will be equal to c d plus y
plus c e plus x
but we know that c f is equal to c d
plus y and c g is equal to c e plus x
so we can substitute these in to get
that the perimeter is equal to cf plus
ce plus x
which then simplifies to be cf plus cg
we can make one more simplification
in particular cf is equal to cg because
of the principle of equal tangence
therefore the perimeter of triangle cd
is equal to two times cf
so this is one way to see that the
perimeter of the triangle is equal to 2
times cf but there's another way that
you could come to this conclusion
so let's go back to our original diagram
now let's imagine
that we move this line d e so that it's
still tangent to the in circle
but it's never specified
where this line has to be
so let's try and get a limiting case
imagine that we move e towards c
now according to the problem this
triangle will still have the same
perimeter and we can continue to move e
towards c
and in the very limiting case we get e
is exactly equal to c
and then c d becomes a tangent to the in
circle
so if we label this tangent point as f
we have the d and f are coincident
so since ce is equal to zero
the perimeter of this triangle c d plus
d e plus c e
is equal to c f
plus c f
which is equal to two times cf so this
is an alternate way to see the perimeter
of triangle cd is also equal to two
times cf
now how can we solve for two times cf
well let's let cf be equal to p over two
this is because it's the perimeter over
two
now let's label our tangent points of
the in circle as g and h
and now what can we do from here
well by the principle of equal tangence
cg will also be equal to p over 2.
next since bc is equal to 5
bg will be equal to 5 minus p over 2.
then we use the principle of equal
tangence to get that bg and bh are equal
to 5 minus p over 2.
we then use that a b is equal to 3
so we get that ah is equal to p over two
minus two
then we use the principle of equal
tangence to get that af is also equal to
p over two minus two
finally we have that c a is equal to six
but we have another expression for c a
and that's equal to p over two minus two
plus p over two
so we can solve this equation that p is
equal to eight and that's exactly the
perimeter of triangle cde
by walking around this triangle using
the principle of equal tangence we
figured out the perimeter of triangle
cde
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they've already gained over a
hundred million views
i think this goal merits millions of
subscribers and billions of views
please help make this possible
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos
watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos
and email me a math topic or puzzle
suggestion at presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you like this video you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and if you so choose you can
financially support this cause on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support